foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with a Daily Mirror
con this Susie Boniface and the sun on
Sunday's political editor Kate Ferguson
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
well the eye describes the chancellor
kwesi cartoon as a betting the UK
economy on tax cuts in the wake of his
mini budget
according to the financial times the
announcements propelled the pound to its
lowest level against the US dollar for
37 years
the gambling metaphor continues on the
front of the telegraph
the times caused the policies trusses
great tax gamble the mail is full of
Praise proclaiming at last a true tory
tax cut
the express likes it too quoting Mr
cuarten saying the government has the
courage to bet big on Britain
but the guardian is blunt in its
assessment branding it a budget for the
rich
and in other news the sun carries claims
about the Duchess of Sussex
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Susie Boniface and Kate Ferguson welcome
to you both let us start with the i
uh on their front page
pound plunges after quite 10 bets UK
economy on tax cuts tax cuts Galore it
seems Susie
yeah and the eye is actually one of the
more balanced front pages so obviously
you've got papers that are protory and
papers that are not Satori but
um
even those that sort of are one side or
the other that they are reporting the
fact that there's big tax cuts and that
the markets aren't happy about it
there's one or two slightly more
unhinged papers that aren't even
mentioning the other side of things but
the eyes being quite balanced about it
so you know fundamentally what's
happened is that quasi-coating has come
out and said I'm going to cut
everybody's taxes I'm going to cut the
rich people's taxis more than the Poor
People's but I'm going to cut
everybody's taxes and I'm going to pay
for it by borrowing money and I'm gonna
borrow that money with taxpayer taxes in
the future and and I'm gonna do it at a
time when it's more expensive to borrow
than it has been for a very long time so
that's why the markets have taken fright
and gone what
because it's all very well cutting taxes
and having a huge fiscal stimulus to
drive growth if the economy is in the
right place for growth but when you've
got inflation that is so volatile we
don't know how much it's going to cost
us to get the bus tomorrow or fill up
the tank or go to the supermarket and do
the weekly shop we have no idea how much
our energy bills are going to cost us
um from one week to the next that's not
the time to throw a big load of money
into the economy and say whoa spend it
everybody because that's only going to
make things worse it's going to bed in a
lot of that inflation for the longer
term have to wait and see what happens
of course if it comes off quasi-quarting
will be the conservatives
um Chancellor of you know the best one
in history as far as they're concerned
uh and and the great Gambler and all the
rest of it and the genius who made it
all come off but um it does look like
there's an awful lot of people on the
conservative back benches tonight who
are
shall we say less optimistic about that
possibility yes Kate whether the defense
uh from the chancellor is that it is
this dash for growth and that is
basically what the the ultimate Pursuit
is of
yeah exactly I mean we've called it a
mini budget it's not it's a gigantic
budget full of tax cuts as as
um you point out all bankrolled by extra
borrowing now you'll see in all the
newspapers this gambling analogy he
really has bet the house on this
strategy number 10 and number 11 think
we've got to go for growth no if no but
I think someone's quoted in the papers
tomorrow saying you've got to go big or
go home so they've adopted this radical
bold and quite you know dangerous
potentially strategy of borrowing tens
of billions to bankroll the biggest tax
cuts in 50 years now Liz trust and quasi
quateng are quite clear they think
there's no other option we have got to
be radical be big if we're going to stop
that sort of stagnant economy sliding
into a deep recession and get growth
back and what's clear in the budget
today is that
they're happy with people earning big
bucks big big amounts of money they're
relaxed about people getting quite Rich
if they think that means they will bring
business and bring growth and bring more
money to the country so really that's
what this budget is about being
unashamedly pro-business and I guess Pro
wealth too but it is controversial it
needs to pay off and it needs to pay off
quickly ahead of the next election and
you'll write lots of story about benches
are kind of holding their breath and
wondering will this work or not tonight
yes it has been labeled a gamble
something that the chancellor has uh
defended against and said that it isn't
a gamble business groups have welcomed
um some of the the sweeping changes but
could this gamble even though the
chancellor says it isn't one could it
pay off Susie
well one of the gambles just move it
aside from the money for a moment and
the fact he's just thrown it all on red
okay that the fact is that there was an
opinion poll out earlier this week that
showed that 51 of everybody in Britain
wanted to pay more tax
46 46 of conservative voters wanted to
pay more tax it is therefore a very bold
chancellor who decides when he's facing
all these people who want to give him
money that he doesn't want any of it and
he's going to give it all back again
um and it also says that I think that's
a piece of an opinion tonight this is 31
of self-employed people a third almost
would vote labor at the next general
election and what he has done here is
that politically again moving the money
to one side he's just handed labor a
massive open goal they they've got their
labor conference uh starting on Sunday
which I'm going to be at and they're
going to be Cocker hoop I would have
thought about this because it's going to
be very very easy for them to look like
the party of fiscal responsibility when
you've got someone who's ignoring the
voters is ignoring his own voters and
he's ignoring some fairly basic maths
and the reason that as Kate was saying
they're calling this a mini budget even
though it is very much a massive budget
really is because if they called us a
budget they would have to open it up to
analysis from independent Financial
experts to actually do some projections
before they could publish it and they
didn't want to do that because the
projections would all be really really
bad so they've called it a mini budget
it's not a budget so they don't have to
have the analysis that stop them doing a
thing that any normal bank manager would
say you're doing what no you're not and
very quickly okay we're running out of
time but the world markets aren't Keen
either are they uh 37-year low against
the dollar
the pound did slump today it's clear I
think that the markets are wobbling a
bit at the kind of I guess audacity or
just scale of today's budget we'll see
where that settles I was going to say I
don't think I've ever met anybody that
wants to pay more tax voluntarily but
that would be a conversation
we are going to um take a breaker at
that point but there must be people that
want to pay more tax because they took
part in the survey isn't that right
Susie
it was it was quite good I think it was
the first time uh in history but it was
it's the British social attitude survey
which have grown for a very long time
and it's very well established and it's
the first time since it's been running
which I think it's about 50 years or so
since the war that they actually found
that more people wanted to pay more tax
than didn't very interesting we shall
take a break on that note to stay with
us coming up the new king gets back to
work but what's on his agenda who will
be discussing that next
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me Susie Boniface and
Kate Ferguson there they are let's um
take a look at the mail we were talking
about um certain viewpoints criticizing
mini budget but the mail their headline
at last a true tory budget they seem to
be in favor of everything that the
chancellor has announced today Susie
yeah not a single word of negativity on
the front page there nothing about the
fact that pound slumped nothing about
the fact that markets aren't too chuffed
nothing about the Fairly reasoned
analysis that it means that some
inflations can be baked into the system
um and it's you know the widest red
mass-market newspaper in the country and
a lot of people who only read that are
only going to see that is a true story
budget and that might backfire because
if the budget gamble doesn't pay off
then again look like a true tory [ __ ] up
won't it but we'll have to wait and see
I mean the fundamental thing that
they're banking on if you like pardon
the pun is that if they can attract big
money Bankers from other Financial
Centers like New York for example or
Frankfurt and come and live in London
that somehow the money they are now
allowed to make in bonuses will end up
in the pocket of a bus driver in Wigan
and that's all well and good if you
think that a banker who's worked in
Frankfurt and New York and is now based
in London is going to be paying his
taxes in London as opposed to paying
them offshore uh which is exactly what
happened when Rishi sunlight was an
international Banker when he said
Javelin was an international banker and
when Jacob Reese mobs an international
Banker they they put all this stuff
offshore because they're in
multi-jurisdictional employment that's
the best way of doing things
um and do you think that they're going
to be sending their children to the
local state school and therefore
encouraging State funding that improves
the schools for everybody else in that
area or do you think they're sending
their children to a private school that
has charitable tax status and is
therefore you know um running a bit of a
business and it's a bit of a fraud
frankly
um no the fact that if you're attracting
lots of Bankers lots of cash
if you're earning more than 155 000
pounds a year are you going to spend all
of it in the UK is it all going on
businesses who pay all their tax in the
UK are you all going to be taking the
bus are you going to be using the trains
are you going to be buying only British
cars it doesn't work that way you know
that's just not how it's going to work
out at all let us move on from the the
mini budget okay only because of time
and just have a look at the telegraph
King Charles uh back to work he's a
photograph there at his desk working
away
yeah it's a lovely photo isn't it this
is a photo taken of Charles I think a
few days ago but it's it's signaling
isn't it that he's after the period of
national mourning the death of his
mother and obviously he's now our King
but he's going back to work
um so I think look you know this
big budget story today is obviously
gobbling up all the headlines but we're
also so much has happened in the past
couple of weeks we're in a new Reign a
new era of King Charles so I think all
eyes also will be on that what he does
with the role and and do we see a big
change between him and and the lake
Queen Elizabeth
so yeah could put Charles is back to
work as is you know quasi quality and
the government although actually they're
off now they're back on Story Party
recess soon so yes Theresa yes and Susie
um the article saying they're sitting at
his desk in the 18th century room in
Buckingham Palace with a photograph of
his parents behind him uh he's shown
signing papers Charles R short for
Charles Rex His official signature is
King
some very carefully arranged papers so
that no one could see anything that
might be remotely too sensitive in there
it looks insanely posed that red box and
in fact in there is a rolled up piece of
parchment tied in Blue Ribbon as though
someone's been sending him missives by
Owl
um it's a bit ridiculous okay still not
send the man an email